what you're about to watch is a clip
from my brand lytics training where i
get together with entrepreneurs thought
leaders who want to build their brand
using youtube and making data driven
decisions to blow up their brand this
year enjoy
so the topic today
how do you reach out to other youtubers
or people in your field to collaborate
with and i'm just going to shorten this
down to collaboration so judging the
value
okay this is a little bit controversial
uh the value of collaborations because
when i was first getting started
everybody said collab collab collab
collab you got to do a lot of collabs
you got a lot of collabs collabs are the
secret answer
it was it was the buzzword i guess at
the time and
i set out to try to do a lot of
collaborations the biggest one that i
did
earlier on in my in my channel growth
was was this one here with charisma on
command this is the biggest one that
i've done the channel that was that was
much bigger than mine right so now he's
got four
and a half million subscribers almost
and he made this video on me talking
about
uh how to be a networker and i never
considered myself to be much of a
networker
but he called it the introvert's guide
to networking he called me a master
networker based off this event that
we're both at for youtubers and i
basically introduced a lot of people to
him uh my strategy for networking was
really just
listen to what people
need and then try to introduce them to
somebody who can help them with that
much more than me going up to people and
say hey i'm evan how are you um i'm i i
suck at that stuff but just basically
listen to what people need
and then help them and so
with charlie uh this is charlie who runs
chris on command that's what i did i
just helped him at the event say hey
what are you trying to find and he he
told me um and i introduced him to a
couple people who i knew
uh and then all of a sudden i'm a master
networker and he's making a video on me
so this video worked out pretty well it
was super um
humbling uh very complimentary and at
the end he even linked up my channel so
i took a screenshot of this end card
because that's if you click on this you
go right to my channel and that's ideal
in collaboration is that it's not just a
link in the description but that they're
actually linking you up on the end card
for them to go right to check out your
channel okay so i thought oh my god my
channel is going to blow up this is
amazing this giant youtuber is featuring
me this is fantastic come on let's go
and then i looked at the data like when
is this video coming up he told me he
was making it it launches let's go come
on my channel channel's about to explode
and then here were the numbers
so this is the day that the video came
out
so these are my subs these are my subs
gains so
i was gaining for this month right from
the from the first to the 17th i was
gaining 1088 subs a day
then when that video came out i got 2
2100 the next day was 1200 and then the
next day was back basically back to my
average
so over the course of you know that
video coming up those two days that it
came up and popped i i got i gained an
extra 1200 subs over my average right an
extra 12 12 over my average and that's
that was pretty good i mean it's decent
it didn't blow up like i thought it
would blow up
it's kind of the you know the heartbreak
every now and then when you think
something's going to do super well and
then it just doesn't get you the results
it really made me start the question is
this even
worth it is it even worth spending all
this time doing this collaboration
versus just making another video i'm
already getting a thousand
you know 88 subs a day
should i just prioritize making videos
instead of trying to set up
collaborations and and after this is
what i ended up really focusing as my
strategy to grow my channel i doubled
down on content creation not
collaborations
it was a big shift i love collaborations
i still do a whole ton of them but i
think for the
the ability to grow your channel the
consistent content is going to be your
number one place to actually get the
results so
uh i've done a ton of collaborations i'm
doing a lot more today this thursday
it's my public facing day
uh so the things to think about
time travel coordination expenses is it
worth the extra effort does it does it
help sure but is it worth all of that
extra effort to try to go off and do the
collaboration now the one with charlie
that i did on chrisman command
i was already in
the
the event with him we were already there
we're in palm springs we're doing this
this
youtube event so i didn't have to do any
real extra work i was just trying to
help them out
and a lot of collaborations have
happened at those events now we don't
obviously have those events happening
right now but at events there's a lot of
collaborations happening at conferences
where they pull you aside and say hey
can i do an interview with you hey can
we make this happen
and so those are always fun to do and
can help your channel but if you're
going to set up a separate thing just to
do it it may not be worth it uh is it is
it worth you to
on the back and forth on the
coordination on the travel and the
expenses all of that
if you're only looking at subs gain
there's other reasons to do it but if
you're only looking at subs gained it
may not be worth it again versus just
making videos
my typical advice is just go back to
default making videos because every
video you make is another shot for
people to find you and it's usually
better for the long term results for
your channel
i would say if they're 10 times bigger
than you those are the collaborations
that go after if it's somebody who's
just your size or smaller if all you
care about is channel growth if there's
no other value you love them it's fun
it's biz dev there's another strategic
reason if all you care about is channel
growth i would be looking at only doing
collaborations with people who are 10
times bigger than you a lot of times the
value just isn't there to do most
collaborations and this is so against
typical advice that people give
but uh this has been my experience from
doing
tons and tons of tons of collaborations
um
that unless they're much bigger than you
it's not going to drive a ton of traffic
okay so then why do it why why do
collaborations why if we don't care
about if it's if it's not going to help
us with channel growth as much as just
making content why do it well the first
is networking right yesterday we were
talking to pre-show two pablo was
talking about my my one-on-one with
jamie kern lima you know she just
created her book believe it we did an ig
live together we're both we both have
our eyes closed here because
uh we're doing a prayer i asked her to
do a prayer live for us and she had
never done a prayer live on instagram so
we did one together
um and we're gonna turn this into a
youtube video so you know jamie i've
known for a year we met i met her at
brendan's uh house in in puerto rico and
she's part of our beach gang and it's
just good it's good karma it's good
networking to support the people in your
community who are doing things she went
from being a waitress and having a
thousand dollars in a bank account to
selling her business for 1.2 billion
cash so
even if it doesn't blow up the channel
it's still good for my business it's
still good for my relationship and it's
still just good karma to do and it's fun
i like doing it right much more than
this video is going to help blow up my
channel
okay brand building
i mean when i do an interview with tony
robbins uh that that could help the
channel obviously uh but it's a it's a
lot of work it's a lot of work lining up
big people it's a lot of work it's a lot
of work reaching out it's a lot of work
maintaining a relationship it's a lot of
work figuring out the times figuring the
technology it's a lot of work to make
this
21 minute interview happen
but it's great for the brand so there
might be people who you bring on who
could really help you with your your
brand that get you're connected to them
even if it doesn't help your channel
grow that much it just puts you into a
different world
so we had
matthew mcconaughey on the channel
recently we're working on deepak chopra
coming up uh you know a bunch of other
people
that
will help the channel grow but probably
not as much as if i just spent time
making videos but having them on the
channel
elevates the brand of the business that
much more
so brand building
bizdev uh this was a client of mine
stephen kelly he used to run sage sage
is an accounting software company uh one
of the the
ftse top hundred companies by market cap
in in the uk and he was the ceo
multi-billion dollar company and we
would do a bi-monthly so every every
two weeks is that bi-monthly or is that
anyway every two weeks we did a show
together on youtube where we would
answer questions from the audience we'd
have a topic and then we'd answer
questions from the audience so
that series didn't help my
channel grow but
but
it was a business opportunity
right i mean if you look at the views on
those videos they probably did worse
than a typical video but it was a
business opportunity and and i grew to
really love steven and his view and his
perspective so it was super fun to do
but again the value isn't just in the
growing the channel the value is in the
business relationship
um and then it's fun
i mean i i think people discount just
having fun is a good thing i'm gonna do
a whole bunch of interviews today and
most of them will be on smaller channels
you know like this one i don't i don't
remember who this guy was um or what his
channel is but it's fun like i just like
i like being the first person on
people's
channels a lot of times i'm the first
person i've ever interviewed and then
they use that interview to go get other
people to say hey we had evan on the
channel do you want to join as well
um so i just find it
super fun to do even if there's no
immediate roi um
one example there's a guy named nick who
i was one of the first guys to reach out
to him he started an instagram account
uh called book thinkers
four years ago when i launched my book
year one word i said nick love the work
you're doing i'd love to send you a copy
of my my book and it was a tiny
instagram account at the time
and
he later said i was the first guy first
author to reach out to him i was the
first author to say to recognize him and
say good work and can i send you a
signed book
fast forward to
now you know three four years later um i
launch built to serve and all of a
sudden nick has the largest network of
instagram accounts for
uh non-fiction
authors right so he's he's profiling
non-fiction book non-fiction book
reviews and he's got the largest network
of instagram accounts for it
and when i said hey i got built to serve
do you want to review it and now i
haven't really been in touch with nick
for the past three years in between that
but when i sent it to him i said yeah
i'm down thank you so much you helped
you helped kick start my instagram
career you were the first author to
support me
and
he he's been a massive help in getting
the word out for bill to serve um i
helped him launch a podcast i was the
first guest on his podcast and then he
had all these other people grant cardone
and jim quick and all those guys on as
well
now i didn't know that nick was going to
be this guy and most people flame out
most people if you're their first guest
on their show most people don't take it
seriously and and stop and quit and they
only
they only go five episodes deep or some
people never even release the episode
they just sit on it it's like whatever
happened to the interview that we did
together like oh i don't know i gave up
but every now and then you get somebody
who pops
and i think it's just it's just fun if
you i see it as fun i see it as
community service i see it as giving
back to
you know entrepreneurs and youtubers
because when i was getting started i
really struggled
and so
i don't care
if it generates traffic or interest for
the channel or not it's not a strategy
it's more just it fills the soul so
probably half the interviews i'm going
to do today after this
are not strategic
just somebody i like or somebody's story
who i like and i want to i want to help
them um and
eventually a lot of those come back to
pay off if you stick in the game long
enough
a lot of those do come back to help
if you want to see this full video as
well as train live with me twice a month
to blow up your brand join the brand
linux training program there's a link to
join right there next to me continue to
believe i'll see you there